Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to generate robots with
grammars.
Wait a second.
Grammars?
Of all things, what do grammars have to do
with robots?
Do we need to teach them grammar to speak
correctly?
No no, of course not!
To answer these questions, let’s invoke
the Second Law Of Papers, which says that
whatever you are thinking about, there is
already Two Minute Papers episode on that.
Even on grammars.
Let’s see if it applies here!
In this earlier work, we talked about generating
buildings with grammars.
So how does that work?
Grammars are a set of rules that tell us how
to build up a structure, such as a sentence
properly from small elements, like nouns,
adjectives and so on.
My friend, Martin Ilcik loves to build buildings
from grammars.
For instance, a shape grammar for buildings
can describe rules like a wall can contain
several windows, below a window goes a window
sill, one wall may have at most two doors
attached, and so on.
A later paper also used a similar concept
to generate tangle patterns.
So this grammar thing has some power in assembling
things after all!
So, can we apply this knowledge to build robots!
First, the robots in this new paper are built
up as a collection of these joint types, links
and wheels, which can come in all kinds of
sizes and weights.
Now, our question is, how do we assemble them
in a way so that they can traverse a given
terrain effectively?
Well, time for some experiments!
Look at this robot.
It has a lot of character, I must say, and
can deal with this terrain pretty well.
Now look at this poor thing.
Someone in the lab at MIT had a super fun
day with this one I am sure.
Now, these can sort of do the job, but now,
let’s see the power of grammars and search
algorithms in creating more optimized robots
for a variety of terrains!
First, a flat terrain.
Let’s see…yes, now we’re talking!
This one is traversing at great speed… and
this one works too.
I like how it was able to find vastly different
robot structures that both perform well here.
Now, let’s look at a little harder level,
with gapped terrains.
Look, oh wow, loving this.
The algorithm recognized that a more rigid
body is required to efficiently step through
the gaps.
And now, I wonder what happens if we add some
ridges to the levels, so it cannot only step
through the gaps, but has to climb?
Let’s see…and we get those long long limbs
that can indeed climb through the ridges.
Excellent!
Now, add a staircase, and see who can climb
these well!
The algorithm says, well, someone with long
arms and a somewhat elastic body.
Let’s challenge the algorithm some more!
Let’s add, for instance, a frozen lake.
Who can climb a flat surface that is really
slippery?
Does the algorithm know?
Look, it says, someone who can utilize a low-friction
surface by dragging itself through it, or
someone with many legs.
Loving this.
Now, this is way too much fun, so let’s
do two more.
What about a walled terrain example?
What kind of robot would work there?
One with a more elastic body, carefully designed
to be able curve sharply, enabling rapid direction
changes.
But it cannot be too long, or else it would
bang its head into the wall.
This is indeed a carefully crafted specimen
for this particular level.
Now, of course, real-world situations often
involve multiple kinds of terrains, not just
one.
And of course, the authors of this paper know
that very well, and also asked the algorithm
to design a specimen that can traverse walled
and ridged terrains really well.
Make sure to have a look at the paper, which
even shows graphs for robot archetypes that
work on different terrains.
It turns out, one can even make claims about
the optimality, which is a strong statement.
I did not expect that at all.
So, apparently, grammars are amazing at generating
many kinds of complex structures, including
robots.
And note that this paper also has a followup
work from the same group where they took it
a step further, and made figure skating and
breakdancing robots.
What a time to be alive!
The link is also available in the video description
for
that one.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!